who's been a healthy scratch for periods of time
this season in the lineup though in his hometown
tonight Mike Mat wait shoots in front Sosi there
it is Josh Anderson bobblehead Knight tonight at
the Bell Center in comes ederland shoots and
montmo a good stop early had a good stretch of
97 and two but it's been ugly since then losing
12 in a row December 12th that last win trying
to get some momentum going as Harris cruising
and shoots up high and black would handle that
over 100 on the season he's sixth in the NHL
and he was a warrior last night as that drive
big petta in front Anderson up the wing puts it
to space for Evans Jake Evans Brendan Gallagher
he'll leave it comes to the line that shot and
a good right pad stop from Blackwood there as
Harris Let It Go Evans drop pass for Harris and
that'll pop out of the zone and the hals will
have to reset and Jake Evans played a lot last
night over 20 minutes of ice time he was one
of the few Habs players who Marty St Louis felt
like had his legs and was really engaged in that
game Yan Ruta takes the look and he'll flip that
into the corner bounces to strubel right in front
score the pass in front and it's Luke cunan the
ice breaker San Jose up one nothing on the road
and as this puck gets dumped in struble's just
trying to make a play it's a harmless dump in
and struble's looking to make a play behind the
net he ends up pumping it right to the middle of
the ice it's a misc it's a mishandle and this
young Decor has got it done offensively big
time for the Montreal Canadians second in the
National Hockey League goals from defenseman
as gie on Q puts it right on from his own Zone up
the left wing to Raphael Harvey penard he'll get
a touch all the way to Blackwood Monahan
chasing and steals Monahan wanted Harvey
penard pass out of his reach mat picks it up
back on Fe what a stop Monahan was all queued
up and Blackwood pushed over Sosi trying to
take the puck away zerland starts the play
up for Thomas hurdle hurdle hits maton Pucket
to the corner hurdle picks it up hurdle zerin
in front score great and Fabian Zin tucks it up
top for his 12th of the Season Two nothing San
Jose well zetland was the main piece that came
back in the team o Meer trade really nice pop
pass to find zedin in the quiet area of the
ice mat does a nice job standing up hurdle at
the Blue Line as he goes into the corner he's
going stick on Puck but hurdle finds a way to
scoop it through the Stick of mat and there's
zerin on the turnover sends it across the bar
for mat mat Rich shot deflected in Anderson
couldn't pop it in Zar again Mattis in in
front G shot score Brandon Giger and Mike
mson has2 200 in his National Hockey League
career as he sets up Brandon Gallagher for his
seventh of the season really nice heads up pass
into the middle of the ice there's good motion
all five players involved mat skates downhill
he's got some room to make a play and Gallagher
finishes it on a one-time opportunity not an
easy pass for mat to make as he's on his backand
he's got a Evans from a knee back on ES skates try
to get it in front Harris near Circle Harris WR
shot right on rebound Anderson jabbing away pux
still loose Anderson and scrolling out Blackwood
and he kept it out example of what an innocent
looking shot on net can do for you offensively
Jordan Harris with a sifter shot to the net that
just goes off the pads of McKenzie Blackwood
but there's Anderson trying to hack away at
it he's not petta far boards checked by leank as
bazetta Falls shark steal the buck leank cutting
in tries to jam it home and mono was strong and
auk feads the left wing up for zerland in space
and it in that shot stopped a good drive what
a chance for kayn Addison Addison takes a point
shot and Jordan Harris gets his stick into
the midsection of Philips Zena getting all
five players involved in the play Criss Crossing
High in the zone herdle spitting away from traffic
Coffield steals Cole Coffield cutting in he tried
to chip it up high takes a big cross check he'll
drop it off to the captain gie bounced on him
couldn't get the shot away cut and lost his stick
gouie circles around Kaden ghy still with it gly
back door feat Sosi in front Puck available and
is jammed out a lot of work for Mike Breer to do
with his hockey team is eckan in shoots Handle by
monmo brandlin behind the net brandlin still
with a puck walking with it back to her feuk
shoots scar what a pass and Nikita auk able to
bury that his first ever goal with San Jose and
just his second goal in the National Hockey League
a really good player Movement by San Jose going
to make his way high in the zone He commands
a lot of the attention and the Canadians get
Puck focused on him he has a lot of room and auk
slides downhill he Creeps in past Jake Evans Jake
Evans doesn't recognize it and it's a slick pass
by granin right onto the tape of ohuk he's able
to beat montmo between the arms and a CO Coffield
pass hit hurdle he'll recover Suzuki lead Lees it
mat far boards picks it up Mike Mat on the puck
he'll stop mat space open he cutting in mat dper
the push and drive it by Blackwood here's Le Bank
he'll guide that high into the corner racing in
Eckland Eckland on the puck brings it in front R
try and monteo able to make the save in comes Luke
cunan for leank leank up the right side round
the net look out he poed it in front alert move
by Le Bank he tries to sneak it into the leg of
monmo and see if he can get a good bounce to go
into the net montmo is able to keep that out of
the net another two period segment or two shift
segment rather for the Canadians where they're
not able to get through the neutral zone not able
to get out of Their Own Zone then he blows a tire
gave it away Saar has Suzuki he can find him Nick
Suzuki he's in the captain to the forehead stopped
by Blackwood doesn't elevate it McKenzie Blackwood
really stretches out Monahan still with possession
Monahan in front off the Stick of slowski
Suzuki for Coffield Coffield ma shoots SC
Mike Mat with the rocket and Montreal within
one on bobble head Anderson the deflection
don't go anywhere does a really good job
here with a shot mentality they're able to come
up with a couple loose pucks and that's the key
eventually Mike Mat is going to get a wide open
shooting Lane and Josh Anderson doing a great job
taking away the eyes of McKenzie Blackwood so
he can't see it Mike Mat leans into a one-time
but it all starts because of their ability to
come up with loose P mat drops Monahan waits
in front Anderson boms lovsky just wide rebound
side of of the net it's Coffield from Monahan
up top sovi shoots just way Coffield tries to
bake it in and then he gets well the shot from
slavkovsky proves to be a dangerous one this is
the weakness in San Jose's coverage right now in
this situation that high player has an opportunity
to get shots through zerland doesn't take the shot
Lane away even though slavkovsky misses the net
and the puck goes off the half while Coffield
tries to bank it in off McKenzie mat for Coffield
Coffield up for mat Coffield one time drive and
Blackwood was ready a good save with the shoulder
Coffield again has room in shoots out was stopped
as well 14 seconds left up top manison boms
deflected just wide C field again 8 seconds
left BS drives one big shot block centerland
bradin finally slaps it down the ice bouncing
puck